[CLICKING]
[RUSTLING]
[SQUEAKING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: OK.
Hi, everybody.
Let's get started.
So, it's been a while since
we came together in a lecture.
Last week, we had the holiday.
We had the midterm.
So with that, what
have we been doing?
We finished the first half of
the course about two weeks ago,
where we talked
about-- we were talking
about computability theory.
We have shifted into
the second half,
talking about complexity theory.
So get your mind back to that.
We discussed the various
different models and ways
of measuring complexity
on different models--
at least in terms of the
amount of time that's used.
And in the end, we settled on
the one-tape Turing machine,
which is the same model
we had been working
with in the first
half of the course,
and argued that though
the measures of complexity
are going to differ somewhat
from model to model,
they're not going to differ by
more than a polynomial amount.
And so, since the
kinds of questions
we're going to be
asking are going
to be, basically, whether
problems are polynomial or not,
it's not going to really
matter which model we
pick among reasonable
deterministic models.
And so, the one-tape Turing
machine is a reasonable choice.
Given that, we defined
time complexity classes,
the TIME[T(n)] classes.
We defined the class P,
which was invariant among all
of those different deterministic
models in the sense
that it didn't matter
which model we choose,
we were going to end
up with the same class
P. So that argues
for its naturalness.
And we gave an example of
this path problem being in P.
And we kind of ended that
lecture before the midterm
with the discussion of this
Hamiltonian path problem.
So we're going to come
back to that today.
So today, we're going to
look at non-non-deterministic
complexity; define the
classes' non-deterministic time
or NTIME; talk about the class
NP, the P versus NP problem--
which one of the very famous
unsolved problems in our field;
and look at dynamic programming,
one of the most basic algorithm
- polynomial-time algorithms and
polynomial-time reproducibility
- moving toward our
discussion of NP completeness,
which we will
begin next lecture.
So with that, let's move
into today's content, which
is, well, just a quick review.
As I mentioned, we defined
the time complexity class.
The time complexity
class is a collection
of all of the
languages that you can
solve in a certain time
bound, within a certain amount
of time.
So the time n-squared,
for example,
is all of the languages
or all of the problems
that you can solve
in n-squared time.
We're identifying problems
with languages here.
And the class P
is the collection
of all problems
that you can solve
or all languages that you
can solve in polynomial time.
So it's the union over
all time n to the k--
so n-squared, n-cubed, n to
the fifth power, and so on.
Union out of all
of those bounds.
The associated languages,
that's the class P.
And we gave an example,
this path problem.
We gave an algorithm for path.
And then, we introduced this
Hamiltonian path problem.
So if you remember?
Instead of just asking
given a graph, whether you
can get from s to t, now we want
to know can I get from s to t,
but visit every other
node along the way.
So find a path that goes
through everything else
and gets from s to t.
And I should say also
it's a simple path,
so you're only allowed to go
through every node just once.
And now, the question
for this problem
is can we solve that
problem in polynomial time.
Can we somehow modify
the algorithm for path
to give us an algorithm
that solves Hamiltonian path
in polynomial time?
Of course, we could
solve Hamiltonian path
with an exponential algorithm
by trying all possible paths.
And that will give
a correct algorithm,
but there are exponentially many
different paths and trying them
all will not give a
polynomial time algorithm.
So the interesting
problem is can we
solve that without doing
that brute force searching
through all possible paths.
And that's a problem that
no one knows the answer to.
Despite lots of
effort, people have not
succeeded in finding
an algorithm for that.
But on the other hand,
we don't have any idea
how do you prove there
is no such algorithm.
I mean, it's conceivable that
one could prove such a thing,
but we just don't
know how to do it.
And so, that problem is
an unsolved problem and I
just-- this isn't
really a note to myself.
What's kind of
amazing, and this is
what we're going to be showing
over the next few lectures,
that there would be very
surprising consequences if you
could find a way to
solve Hamiltonian path
in polynomial time.
Because what that
would immediately yield
is the polynomial time way of,
say, factoring large numbers
or solving a large
number of other problems
that we don't know how to
solve in polynomial time.
So as we mentioned,
factoring is a problem
that we only know at
present how to solve
with an exponential algorithm.
And it doesn't seem
to have anything
to do with the
Hamiltonian path problem.
Seem very different.
But, yet, if you can
solve Hamiltonian path
in polynomial time, then
you can factor numbers
in polynomial time.
And so, we'll see how
to make that connection.
That's what we're
building toward
with the next few lectures.
OK.
So happy to take any comments
and questions on that,
or we'll just move on,
if you have any questions
on our little review.
Well, send questions
along and we
can stop at the end of various
slides to try to answer them.
And, of course,
write to the TAs,
who can take your questions
while I'm lecturing.
OK.
So to start this
off, we're going
to have to talk about
non-deterministic complexity
as a variation of
deterministic complexity.
So first of all,
all of the machines
in this part of the course
and the languages, everything
is going to be decidable
and all the machines
are going to be deciders.
So what do we mean when we have
a non-deterministic machine
which is a decider?
And that just simply means
that all of the branches--
it's not just the machine
halts on every input,
but all of the branches
halt on every input.
So the non-deterministic
machine is non-deterministic,
it has lots of
possible branches.
They all have to halt--
all of them-- on every input.
That's what makes a
non-deterministic machine
a decider.
And you're going to convert
a non-deterministic decider
into a deterministic decider.
But the question is, how much
time would that introduce?
How much extra time
is that going to cost?
And the only way
that people know
at the present time
for that conversion
would be to do an
exponential increase.
Basically, to try all
possible branches.
And that's, of
course, very slow.
So first, let's
understand what we
mean by the time used by a
non-deterministic machine.
And what we mean
by the time used
is, we're looking at
each individual branch
individually, separately.
So a non-deterministic
machine, we'll say,
runs in a certain amount of
time if all of the branches
halt within that amount of time.
So what we do not mean that
the total amount of usage,
the total amount of effort
by adding up all the branches
is at most T of n.
It's just that each branch
individually uses at most
T of n.
That's just going to
be our definition.
And it's going to turn
out to be the right way
to look at this to
get something useful.
So now we're going to define
the analogous complexity
class associated to
non-deterministic computation,
which we'll call
non-deterministic time.
So non-deterministic time T of
n is the set of all languages
that you can do with a
non-deterministic machine that
runs in order T of n time.
Just think back
to the definition
we had for deterministic
complexity, the time class--
or sometimes people
call it dtime
to emphasize the difference.
But let's just say we're
calling it in this course
time versus ntime.
So TIME[T(n)] is all of the
language that you can do with
the one-tape Turing machine
that's deterministic.
But this here is a
non-deterministic Turing
machine for
non-deterministic time.
So the picture that is
good to have in your head
here would be if you
think of non-determinism
in terms of a computation
tree thinking of all
the different branches
of the non-determinism.
All of those
branches have to halt
and they have to halt
within the time bound.
So imagine, here,
this is T of n time.
All of the branches have to halt
within T of n steps for this,
a non-deterministic Turing
machine to be running in T of n
time and to be doing a language
in the NTIME[T(n)] class.
And by analogy with
what we did before,
the class NP is the
collection of all languages
that you can do
non-deterministically
in polynomial time.
So it's the union over all
of the ntime classes where
the bound is polynomial.
OK, so a lot of this
should look very familiar,
but we've just added a
bunch of non-deterministic
and a bunch of Ns in place.
But the definitions
are very similar.
And one of the motivations we
had for looking at the class P
was that it did not depend
on the choice of model,
as long as the model was
deterministic and reasonable.
And the class NP is
also going to not
depend on the
choice of model, as
long as it's a reasonable
non-deterministic model.
So it's again a
very natural class
to look at from a
mathematical standpoint.
And it also captures something
interesting, kind of,
from a practical
standpoint - which
we're going to talk about
over the next couple of slides
- which is that it captures the
problems where you can easily
verify when you're a
member of the language.
OK, so we'll talk about that.
But if you take, for example,
the Hamiltonian path problem.
When you find a member
of the language,
so that is a graph that
does have a Hamiltonian
path from s to t,
you can easily verify
that's true by simply
exhibiting the path.
Not all problems can be
verified in that way.
But the problems that are in
NP have that special feature--
that when you have a
member of the language,
there's a way to verify
that you're a member.
So we're going to talk about
that, because that's really
the key to understanding NP--
this notion of verification.
OK, so let me go-- there
was a good question here.
Let me just see if I
want to answer that.
Yeah, I mean, this is a little
bit of a longer question
than I want to fully
respond to but--
well, let's turn to my
next slide, which maybe
sort bringing that out anyway.
Actually, it's a couple
of slides from now.
But I'll get to that point.
So let's look at Hamiltonian,
the hampath problem.
And what I'm going to show is
the Hamiltonian path problem
is in NP.
And I'm going to walk
you through this one
kind of slowly.
So the Hamiltonian
path problem, remember,
we don't know if it's
in P. But it is in NP.
So it's in one of these.
You can solve Hamiltonian
path in polynomial time
if you're a
non-deterministic machine.
Why is that?
Well, it's because of the
parallelism of non-determinism,
which allows you
to kind of check
all of the paths on
different branches.
So let me first describe how I
would write down the algorithm.
And then, we'll kind of try
to unpack that and understand
how that actually looks in
terms of the Turing machine's
computation.
So first of all, taking the
Hamiltonian path problem,
you are given an input
now, which is a graph
and the nodes s and t where
I'm trying to figure out
is that Hamiltonian path--
again, which visits
all the nodes,
which takes you from s to t.
And we're trying to make now
a non-deterministic machine,
which is going to accept all
such inputs which have a path.
So the way this
non-deterministic machine
is going to work
is it's basically
going to use its non-determinism
to try all possible paths
on the different branches.
And the way I'll
specify that is to say,
non-deterministically,
we're going
to write down a candidate
path which is just
going to be a
sequence of m nodes,
where we will say that's
the total number of nodes
of the graph.
Remember, a Hamiltonian path,
because it visits every node,
is going to be a path with
exactly m nodes in it.
So I'm going to write
down a sequence of nodes
as a candidate path.
And I'm
non-deterministically going
to choose every possible
sequence in this way.
If you'd like to think
of the guessing metaphor
for non-determinism,
you can think
of the non-deterministic
machine as guessing
the right path, which is going
to be the Hamiltonian path
from s to t.
But I think for
this discussion, it
might be more helpful
to think about all
of the different branches
of the non-determinism.
Because that's
perhaps more useful
when we're thinking about
it in terms of the time.
I think you'll get used
to thinking about it.
You should be used
to thinking about it
in many of the different
ways. but maybe
the computation
tree of all branches
might be the more
helpful one here.
So now after we write
down a candidate path
sequence of nodes,
now I have to check
that this really is a path.
And the way I'm going to do that
is to say, well, now if I have
just a sequence of
nodes written down, what
does it mean for it to be a
Hamiltonian path from s to t?
Well, it better start with s
and end with t, first of all.
And we have to make sure
that every step of the way
is actually an edge.
So each pair vi to vi plus 1
has to be an edge in the graph.
Otherwise, that
sequence of nodes
is not going to be a legitimate
Hamiltonian path from s to t.
And it has to be a simple path.
You can't be repeating nodes.
These four conditions
together will
guarantee that we have
a Hamiltonian path.
And once we have written
down a candidate sequence,
we can just check that the
sequence actually works.
At this second stage
of the algorithm,
non-determinism isn't necessary.
This is going to be a
deterministic phase.
But stage one of
the algorithm is
going to be a non-deterministic
phase where it's writing down
all possible paths.
Now, I'm going to try
to unpack that for you
so you can actually visualize
how the machine is doing this.
And then, of course,
you know on each branch
of the non-determinism,
you're going
to check to see whether the
conditions have been satisfied.
And on that branch, if the
conditions were not satisfied,
that branch is going to reject.
Of course, one of the other
branches might yet accept,
so that's how
non-determinism works.
OK?
So I'd like to visualize
this as the tree
of the different branches of the
computation of m on its input.
So here is our non-deterministic
Turing machine.
Which?
This one.
And you provide it with
the input G, s, and t.
And how is the machine
actually working?
So when I say
non-deterministically write
down a sequence of m nodes--
look, this is getting into
a little bit more detail
than I would normally
think about it,
because we try to tend to think
about things at a higher level.
But just to get us
started, I think
it's good to think about
this with a bit more detail.
So let's think of the m nodes
as being numbered, having
labels numbered 1 through m.
And I'm going to think
about them being labeled
by their binary sequences.
We're going to write
down those nodes.
That's how the machine is
going to have to operate
on those numbers for the nodes.
We'll think about them as
being written in binary.
And now, as the machine is
going to be writing down,
let's say, the node v1.
So it's
non-deterministically picking
the first node of the sequence.
What does that
actually mean in terms
of the step-by-step processing
of the Turing machine m?
Well, it's going to be
guessing via a sequence
of non-deterministic moves,
the bits that represent
the number of the node for v1.
For example, v1 might be the
node number 5 in the graph.
Of course,
non-deterministically,
the machine is on
different branches,
picking all different
possible choices for v1.
Those are going to be the
different branches here.
But one of the
branches might be--
and what I'm really
representing here, these are--
I probably could have written
this down on the slide
here in tiny font.
But these are like
the 0, 1 choices.
That's why it's sort
of a binary tree
here for writing
down the bits of v1.
So here maybe this could be
101, representing the number
5, which might be the very
first node that I'm writing down
in my sequence.
Some other branch is going
to write down node number 6.
to write down node number 2.
Because
non-deterministically, we're
making all possible
choices for v1.
That's what I'm trying to
show in this little part
of the computation
of m on this input.
So then, after it's
finished writing down
the description of the
node for its choice for v1,
it goes down to
choose what v2 is.
Again, non-deterministically,
so there's
going to be more branches for
each possible choice of v2.
And so on, node after node.
Then, it's going to finally
get to the last node, vm.
It's going to write down
lots of choices for vm.
And at this point here, we
have completed the first stage
of the algorithm.
Now, there's some
huge tree of all
of the possible choices
for the V's that
have shown up at this point.
OK?
And now, we're going to
move into the second phase.
So following this,
there's going to be,
here, a bunch of deterministic
steps of the machine.
So no more branching
is needed because here,
we've written down--
at this point,
we've reached a point in
each of those locations,
where we've chosen
one of the candidates,
one of the possible branches--
one of the possible paths
through the graph, I'm sorry.
So here, we're guessing
potential paths in the graph.
And now, we're going to
check that we actually
have picked a path that's a
Hamiltonian path from s to t.
OK?
So each one of these
branches is now
going to end up
accepting or rejecting.
And the whole
overall computation
is going to accept if
at least one of them
ended up accepting,
which means you actually
found a Hamiltonian path.
OK?
I don't know if that's helpful
to you or not, but that is--
if there's any questions
on this, let's see.
Question on is there something--
trying to draw a connection here
between this and computation
histories.
I mean, there is a pattern
here that does come up often
where you want to check
that something starts right,
ends right, and that all of
the intermediates are right.
So I think there is some
deeper connection here.
Probably too hard
to explain but that
has something to do with this
Hamiltonian path problem.
Why are we using
binary representation?
Well, we're going
to talk about--
the algorithm would
have worked equally well
if we used base three
or base five or base 20
as a way of writing down
our labels for the nodes.
But in a sense,
it doesn't matter.
The alphabet has to be finite
though, so that's true.
I mean, that's why it's not just
in a single step of the Turing
machine that you would pick
the node the choice for v1.
You really have to go
to a sequence of steps.
Because each of the
branches of the machine
only has a fixed
number of choices.
So you can't, in a single
step of the Turing machine,
pick all the different
possibilities for v1.
That has to go
through a sequence.
OK.
Now, let me do a second example,
the problem of composites.
So the language
of all composites
are all of the non-primes,
written as binary numbers
again.
So we'll talk about the base and
the representation in a second.
But just imagine these
are all of the numbers
that are not prime.
And that language is easily
seen to be a member of NP.
Here is, again, the
algorithm for that.
Given x, we want to accept x,
if it's not a prime number.
So it has some
non-trivial factor.
So first, the way the
non-deterministic machine
is going to work is it's
going to guess that factor.
So non-deterministically,
it's going
to try every possible factor.
Y is going to be a
number between 1 and x.
But not including 1.
You have to be an
interesting factor,
so not including one
in the number itself.
So something
strictly in between.
And we're going to then--
after we've
non-deterministically chosen y,
then we're going to test to
see if y is really a factor.
So we'll see if y divides evenly
into x with a remainder of 0.
If that branch successfully
picked the right y,
it's going to accept.
And some other branch where it
might have picked the wrong y,
will not.
And if x is really
a composite number,
some branch will
find the factor.
Now, the base doesn't matter.
Could have used base 10, because
you can convert from one base
to another.
So this is really in terms
of our representation
of the number.
But I do want to make one
point here, that changing--
we don't want to write
the number in unary--
writing the number of
k as a sequence of k1s.
That's not really a base.
That's just an exponential
representation for the number
and that changes the game.
Because if you make the
input exponentially larger,
then it's going to change
whether the algorithm
relative to that exponentially
larger input is polynomial
or not.
So an algorithm that might have
been exponential originally
when the number's
written in binary
might become polynomial if the
numbers are written in unary.
And I do want to
mention as a side note,
that the composites language--
or primes, for that matter--
both are NP.
But we won't cover that.
So whereas the Hamiltonian
path problem is not
known whether it's NP, the
primes and composites problem
are NP.
So that was known.
That was actually a very
big result in the field.
Solved by folks at one of the
Indian Institute of Technology
back about almost
20 years ago now.
So let's turn here, to
trying to get an intuitive
feeling for P and NP.
And we'll return now to this
notion of NP corresponding
to easy verifiability.
NP are the languages where you
can easily verify membership
quickly.
I'll try to explain
what that means.
In contrast, P are the languages
where you can test membership
quickly.
By quickly, I'm using
polynomial time.
That's going to be,
for us, that's what
quickly means in this course.
In the case of the
Hamiltonian path problem,
the way you verify
the membership
is you give the path.
In the case of the
composites, the way
you verify the membership
is you give the factor.
In those two cases,
and in general,
when we have a
problem that's in NP,
we think of this
verification as having--
we give it a special name,
called a certificate,
or sometimes a
short certificate,
to emphasize the polynomiality
of the certificate.
It's like a way of
proving that you're
a member of the language.
In the case of COMPOSITES,
the proof is the factor.
In the case of
HAMPATH, the proof
is the path, the
Hamiltonian path.
Contrast that, for example,
if you had a prime number.
Proving a number is composite
is easy because you just
exhibit the factor.
How would you prove
that a number is prime?
What's the short
certificate of proving
that some number has no factor?
That's not so obvious.
In fact, there are
ways of doing it,
which I'm not going to get
into in the case of testing
of numbers prime.
And now it's even known to be
in P, so that's even better.
But there's no obvious way
of proving that a number is
prime with a short certificate.
This concept of
being able to verify
when you are a member
of the language, that's
key to understanding NP.
That's the intuition you
need to develop and hopefully
take away from today's
lecture, or at least
by thinking about it,
reading the book, and so on.
If you compare these
two classes, P and NP.
P, first of all, is going
to be a subset of NP,
both in terms of the
way we defined it
because, deterministic
machines are
a special case of
non-deterministic machines.
But also if you want to think
about testing membership,
if you can test
membership easily
then you can certainly verify
it in terms of the certificate.
You don't even need it.
The certificate is
irrelevant at that point.
Because whatever
the certificate is,
you can still test
yourself whether the input
is in the language or not.
The big question,
as I mentioned,
is whether these two
classes are the same.
So does being able to verify
membership quickly, say
with one of these certificates,
allow you to dispense
with the certificate?
Not even need a
certificate and just test
it for yourself whether
you're in the language.
And do that in polynomial time.
That's the question.
For a problem like
Hamiltonian path,
do you need to
search for the answer
if you're doing it
deterministically?
Or can you somehow
avoid that and just
come up with the answer
directly with a polynomial time
solution?
Nobody knows the answer to that.
And it goes back, at this
point, quite a long time.
It's almost 60 years now.
That problem has
been around 60 years.
No, that would be 50 years.
No, 50 years, almost 50 years.
Most people believe that
P is different from NP.
In other words, that
there are problems in P--
in NP which are not
in P. A candidate
would be the Hamiltonian
path problem.
But it seems to be very
hard to prove that.
And part of the
reason is, how do you
prove that a problem
like Hamiltonian path
does not have a
polynomial time algorithm.
It's very tricky to do
that, because the class
of polynomial time algorithms
is a very rich class.
Polynomial time algorithms
are very powerful.
And to try to prove--
there's no clever way
of solving the
Hamiltonian path problem.
It just seems to be beyond
our present day mathematics.
I believe someday somebody's
going to solve it.
But so far, no
one has succeeded.
So what I thought
we would do is--
I think I have a check-in here.
Yes.
And then we'll stop for a break.
Let's look at the complementary
problem, HAMPATH complement.
You're in the language now
if you don't have a path.
So is that complementary
problem in NP?
For that to be
the case, we would
need to have short certificates
of when a graph does not
have a Hamiltonian path.
I leave it to you.
There are three choices.
OK?
Going to stop here, so make
sure you get your participation
credit here.
I'm going to end
the polling now.
Interesting.
[LAUGHS] So the
majority is wrong.
Well, not wrong, we don't know.
I think the only fair
answer to this question
is C. Because we don't
know whether or not
we can give short
certificates for a graph
not to have a Hamiltonian path.
If P equaled NP, then you
can test in polynomial time
whether a graph has
a Hamiltonian path.
And then the computation
itself would be a certificate,
whether it has a path or
whether it doesn't have a path.
Because it would be something
that you can check easily.
Since we don't know for sure
that P is different from NP,
P could be equal to
NP, then it's possible
that we could give
a short certificate.
Namely, the computation of
the polynomial algorithm.
So the only really reasonable
answer to this question
is that we don't know.
Just ponder that.
Those of you who answered
yes, however, need to go back.
And I put this here
explicitly because I
know this is a confusion
for, well I can
see, for quite a few of you.
When we have
non-deterministic computation
and you have a
non-deterministic machine,
you can't simply
invert the answer
and get back a
non-deterministic machine.
Non-determinism does
not work that way.
If you remember, the complement
of a pushdown automaton
is not a pushdown automaton.
If you have a
non-deterministic machine
and you invert all of
the responses on each
of the branches, it's not going
to be recognizing or deciding
the complementary language.
I think that this
is something you--
if you answered yes, you
need to go back and make
sure you understand why yes
is not a reasonable answer
to this question.
Because that's not how
non-determinism works.
So you have a not
complete understanding
of non-determinism.
And that's going to be really
important for us going forward.
I really urge you to figure out
and understand why yes is not
a good answer to this check-in.
OK, so I think we will--
we can talk about that
more over the break.
And so we'll return
here in five minutes.
Somebody's asking about--
can infinite sequences
be generated by the machine.
When we're talking
about, especially
in the complexity section of the
course, all of the computations
are going to be bounded in time.
So we're not going to be
thinking about infinite runs
of the machine.
That's not going to
be relevant for us.
So let's not think about that.
How does a Turing
machine perform division?
Well, how do you
perform division?
[LAUGHS] Long division is an
operation that can run in--
the long division procedure
that you learn in grade school,
you can implement that
on a Turing machine.
Yes, a Turing machine
can definitely perform--
do long division, or
division of one integer
by another in polynomial time.
Another question.
Can we generally say,
try dividing y by x?
Or do we have to enumerate
a string of length y
and cross off every-- no.
I think that's
the same question.
I mean, if you have
numbers written in binary,
how would you do the division?
You're not going to
use long division.
Anything such as
the thing that's
proposed here by the
questioner is going
to be an exponential algorithm.
So don't do it that way.
Why does primes in P--
composites in P not
imply primes in P?
It does imply.
If composites are in P,
then primes is in P as well.
When you have a
deterministic machine,
you can flip the answer.
When you have a
non-deterministic machine,
you may not be able
to flip the answer.
So deterministic machine
just having a single branch,
you can make another
deterministic machine
that runs in the same
amount of time that does
the complementary language.
Because for
deterministic machines,
just like for deciders in
the computability section,
you can just invert the answer.
There is an analogy here
between P and decidability,
and NP and recognizability.
It's not an airtight
analogy here,
but there is some
relationship there.
Somebody's asking me, what
are the implications of P
equal to NP?
Lots of implications.
Too long to enumerate now.
But, for example, you
would be able to break
basically all cryptosystems that
I'm aware of, if P equal to NP.
So we would have a
lot of consequences.
Somebody's asking,
so composites--
primality and
compositeness testing
is solvable in polynomial time.
But factoring,
interestingly enough,
is not known to be solvable
in polynomial time.
We may talk about this a little
bit toward the end of the term
if we have time.
The algorithms for testing
whether a number is
prime or composite
in polynomial time
do not operate by
looking for factors.
They operate in an entirely
different way, basically
by showing that a number is
prime or composite by looking
at certain properties
of that number.
But without testing
whether it has--
testing, but without
finding a factor.
Another question
here about asking
when we talk about
encodings, do we
have to say how we
encode numbers, values?
No, we don't have to.
We usually don't have to get
into spelling out encodings,
as long as they're
reasonable encodings.
So you don't have to usually.
We're going to be talking about
things at a high enough level
that the specific encodings
are not going to matter.
Let's return to the
rest of our lecture.
When we talk about, say,
this P versus NP problem.
And how do you show
that a problem might not
be solvable in P, like the
Hamiltonian path problem?
Many people who are not
practitioners in the field,
know about the P
versus NP problems--
over the years, I've
gotten many, many emails
and physical letters
from people about that.
Since I've spent
some time thinking--
I'm known as having spent
some time thinking about it.
People claim to
solve the problem,
solve P is NP, the P versus NP
problem, by basically saying,
problems like Hamiltonian path
or other similar problems,
basically there's clearly no way
to solve them without searching
through a lot of possibilities.
And then they go through
a big, long analysis
showing that there
are exponentially
many possibilities.
A lot of the proofs that
claim to solve P versus NP,
they all look like that.
You only have to look--
somewhere in that
paper, there's going
to be a statement along the
lines, "to solve this problem,
clearly you have
to do it this way."
And that's the flaw
in the reasoning.
Because just like for
the factoring problem--
just like for the
compositeness testing problem,
you don't necessarily
have to solve it
by searching for factors.
There might be some
other way to do it.
You might be able to
solve the Hamiltonian path
problem without searching
for Hamiltonian paths.
There might be some other
process that you can use,
which would give you the answer.
The class of polynomial
time algorithms
is very rich, can do
many, many things.
And I wanted to present to
you one of the most important
polynomial time algorithms.
In a sense, you can
make a certain argument
that this is the most
fundamental polynomial time
algorithm.
Some people might
argue with me on that.
And that's a process called
dynamic programming, which
I'm sure some of you
have seen already
in your algorithms classes,
and some of you may not have.
Since you have a
homework problem on it,
I want to spend a little
time describing it to you.
And that's useful for solving
this A CFG problem, which
you may remember from the
first half of the course,
involving testing if a
grammar generates a string.
So you remember
this A CFG problem?
You're giving a grammar,
context-free grammar,
and a string.
And I want to know, is it in
the language of the grammar.
So that's going to turn out to
be solvable in polynomial time,
but only with kind of
a clever algorithm.
Remember, it's decidable.
We decided it by
making sure that you
are converting the grammar
in Chomsky normal form.
Then all the derivations
have a certain length.
You just try all the possible
derivations of that length,
and you accept if any of
those derivations generate w.
You may remember that from
the first half of the course.
That immediately
gives an NP type
algorithm for this language.
Because basically, you
non-deterministically--
instead of trying the
most sequentially, all
of these derivations,
you try them
in parallel
non-deterministically.
So non-deterministically,
you pick some derivation
of that length.
And you accept it if
it generates the input.
This classically
fits our model of NP.
You can think of it as
guessing the derivation
and checking that it works.
Or, in parallel, writing down
all possible derivations.
But this A CFG
problem is classically
an NP problem, a problem in NP.
And if you just imagine--
then what's going to
be the certificate?
If you found an input that's
in the language, that's
generated by the grammar, the
certificate is the derivation.
So if you look at
it that way, you
might think, well, that's
the best you can do.
This is going to be
an NP problem, in NP,
and is not going to
be a way of avoiding
searching for the derivation.
But that's not true.
There is a way of avoiding
searching for the derivation.
You can build up the derivation
using dynamic programming.
And so that's what I
wanted to describe for you,
how that works.
Also partly because
it's a homework problem.
And I think dynamic programming
is a very important algorithm.
Before we describe what
dynamic programming is,
which is very
simple, by the way,
let's try to work up to
it by making an attempt
to solve this problem just
using ordinary recursion.
How would we solve
the A CFG problem?
So you're given grammar,
you're given an input.
Let's assume the grammar
is in Chomsky normal form.
That's going to be useful.
So it's a Chomsky
normal form grammar.
And we want to see how to
test if you can generate w.
And it's going to be
recursive algorithm.
The recursive algorithm is going
to actually solve something
slightly more general.
I'm going to give
you the grammar.
you the string.
And I'm also going to allow you
to start at some other variable
besides the start variable.
I'm going to give
you some variable, R,
and I know I want to know, can
I generate w starting at R?
So that's my slightly
more general problem,
which is going to be
useful in the recursion.
So the input now
to this algorithm
is the grammar, the input,
and the starting variable.
And now how is the
algorithm going to work?
It's going to try to
test, can I get to--
is there some
derivation, pictured here
as the parse tree,
for w starting at R?
That's what the algorithm
is trying to answer.
Can I get w from R?
The way it's going to do that
is it's going to try to divide w
into the two strings
in all possible ways.
Which sounds like it might
be exponential, but it isn't.
There's only a polynomial
number of ways to divide
the string into two substrings.
Just of order n, just depending
where you make that cut.
So that's not too bad.
There's a polynomial,
there's only n ways
of making that division.
And also I'm going to try every
possible rule that comes from R
that generates two variables.
So these are what's allowed
in Chomsky normal form,
R goes to ST.
For each possible way
of cutting w into x, y,
and for each
possible rule, R goes
to ST, I'm going to see,
recursively, can I get
from S to x, and from T to y.
So I'm going to use
my recursion now.
Now that I have smaller
strings instead of w,
I can apply recursion and
try to answer it that way.
And this algorithm will work.
If I found a way to cut w
into x, y, and I found a rule,
R goes to ST such that S
generates x and T generates y,
then I'm good.
I know I can generate w from R.
And if there's no way of
cutting w up to satisfy that,
or if I can't find any
way to divide w into x, y,
and a rule R goes
to ST which makes
this work, if all
possible ways fail
then you can't get from R to w.
And then you can decide the
original A CFG problem now,
by starting from
the start variable,
instead of just
any old R. You plug
in the start variable for R.
So this algorithm works, and
it can be used to solve A CFG.
But the question is,
is it polynomial?
And it's not.
Because every time you're
doing the recursion,
you're essentially adding
another factor of n.
Because here, as we pointed
out, this is a factor of n.
But that's happening every time
you're doing a recursive level.
And you can imagine, I'm just
doing a very crude analysis
here, depending upon
how you divide w up.
But roughly speaking,
it's going to get
divided in half each
time, so there's
going to be log n levels.
So that means you're
going to be multiplying n
by itself log n
times, or give you
an n to the log n algorithm.
That's not polynomial,
because polynomials
end with a constant,
for some fixed constant.
n to the log n is not
going to be polynomial.
This is not a
polynomial algorithm.
Instead, you're going to have to
do something just a little bit
more clever.
It's going to be
the same basic idea,
but relying on one
little observation.
And the little
observation is that when--
this non-polynomial
implementation
that I've just described
is actually pretty dumb.
Because it's doing a lot
of recomputation of things
that it's already solved.
Why is that?
Because if you
look at the number
of possible different
subproblems here,
once I give you G
and I give you w,
how many different subproblems
of G, S, and T are there?
The number of strings
here, all of those strings
are going to be substrings of w.
There's only roughly n
squared substrings of w.
I'm always going
to be generating,
in a subproblem here,
some substring of w
from some starting
variable in the grammar.
So because there aren't that
many different substrings,
and not that many different
starting variables,
the total number of
possible problems
that this algorithm is going
to be called on to solve
is going to be, in total,
a polynomial number
of different subproblems.
There aren't very many of them.
It's only something
like order of n squared.
So if the algorithm is running
for exponentially long time,
it's solving the same
subproblem over and over again.
That's dumb.
Why don't you just remember
when you solve the subproblem,
so you don't solve it again?
Doing that enhanced
recursion where
you remember the problems
you've already solved,
it's called dynamic programming.
I don't know why it has such
a confusing name like that.
Actually it's called by
several different things.
But anyway, that's known
as dynamic programming.
It's recursion plus the memory.
And here is just
repeating myself.
There are not very many
different substrings,
so every time in your
recursion somewhere,
you're going to be
working with a substring.
So there's not that many
different subproblems
that you can possibly solve.
And just remember when
you solve the subproblem,
and not solve it again.
Let me just show you that
algorithm again here,
with the little modification.
So first of all,
let me give you--
this is the same algorithm
from the previous slide.
I'm just repeating it here
without all the other stuff
so we can look at it directly.
Dividing it into x and y
for each possible rule.
And then recurse.
I'm going to add a little
step 0 beforehand, which
says, if I have G, w, and R,
let me just check first if I've
already solved that one before.
So I have to keep track of
the ones I've already solved.
That's not too bad,
because there's
only order n squared possible
different ones that I
could be called on to solve.
So I'm just going to
have a little table where
I'm going to remember those.
And then every time I get a
new one, I get one to solve,
I'll check.
Is it on that table?
And what's the answer?
So I won't have to rerun those.
I'm going to be basically
pruning that tree so
that it has only a
polynomial number of leaves.
And so the total
size of that tree
now is going to be polynomial.
And so that's going to yield
a polynomial running time.
This, by the way,
I only learned this
myself, I'm sure you guys all
know this who have taken this
in the algorithms course,
has a special name called
memoization.
Not memorization.
Came from the same root,
I think, but memoization,
which is somehow remembering
the results of a computation
so you don't have to repeat it.
The total number
of calls is going
to be, at most, n squared, to
this algorithm, because you're
never going to be redoing
work that you've done already.
And when you actually have to go
through it, the running time--
the total amount of time
that you're going to need
is going to be
polynomial altogether.
I don't remember what
my check-in is on this.
Oh yeah.
This is somehow related.
And feel free to
ask questions too,
while you're thinking
about this check-in.
But the check-in
says here, we've
solved the A CFG problem
in polynomial time.
Does that tell us that every
context-free language itself
is also solvable
in polynomial time?
Just mull that over, and
please give me an answer to it.
I hope you do better
on this check-in
than you did on the last one.
But anyway, why don't you go
ahead and think about that.
I can take some questions
in the meantime.
Somebody is asking here--
actually, I'm getting
several questions on this.
Why isn't it order n
cubed or something greater
than order n squared
because of the variables?
The variables don't depend on n.
When you're given-- well,
actually that's not true.
No.
You are right.
Because the grammar
is part of the input.
So you might have as many
as n different variables
in the given grammar.
So you are right.
There is potentially--
the grammar might
be half the size of the input,
and the input to the grammar w
might be half the
size of the input.
So I didn't think about
that, but you're correct.
There are potentially
different numbers
of variables in
different grammars,
so you have to add an
extra factor, which
would be at most the
size of the input,
because that's as many variables
as you could possibly have.
So it really should be, I think,
order n cubed to take that
into account as well.
Plus all of the work
that needs to happen
in terms of dividing things up.
On a one-tape Turing
machine, there's
going to be some extra
work just to carry out
some of these individual steps,
because with a single tape
things are sometimes
a little awkward.
I think the total
running time is
going to end up being
something like n
to the 4th or into the 5th
on a one-tape Turing machine.
But that's a good point.
Somebody's saying, how can we
be storing n squared strings
in finite time?
I'm not saying finite time.
We have polynomial time.
Every stage of this
algorithm is allowed
to run for polynomially
many steps.
As long as it's
clearly polynomial,
we can just write that
down as a single stage.
Part two should say--
oh.
There's a typo here.
So use D. Thank you.
That is a typo.
I'm afraid if I change it
on my original slide here,
things will break in
some horrible way.
Let's just see.
Did I completely wreck my slide?
No, that's good.
Yeah, thank you.
Good point.
Oops.
OK, how's our check-in doing?
I think you're just
about all done.
Spent a lot of time on this.
End polling.
As you may remember from the
first half of the course--
so the answer is A, indeed.
Remember that we showed
A CFG is decidable,
and therefore each
context-free language
itself is decidable,
just because you
can plug in a specific grammar
into the A CFG problem.
The very same
reasoning works here.
If you have a context-free
language, it has a grammar.
You can plug that grammar
into the A CFG problem.
And then, that's
polynomial time,
you're going to get
a polynomial time
algorithm for that language.
Good to review that.
It's the same thing, same
argument we used before.
I don't want to spend
a lot of time on this.
There's another way of looking
at dynamic programming.
We'll talk about this again
maybe in a lecture, probably
next lecture, just because I you
have a homework problem on it.
If you've seen dynamic
programming before,
this is going to be easy.
If you haven't seen it
before, it's going to be,
I think, probably a
little challenging.
Another way of looking
at dynamic programming
is the so-called bottom-up
version of dynamic programming.
And what that would
mean is, you solve
all of the subproblems first.
You solve all the smaller
subproblems before you
solve the larger subproblems.
It's here on the slide.
I'm not sure I want
to talk it through.
But basically, you solve
the subproblems here
where, start with
strings of length 1,
and then from that you
build up to subproblems
with the substrings are
of length 2, and then 3,
and so on.
And each of those only relies
on the smaller previously solved
subproblems.
So you can, kind of
in a systematic way,
solve all the larger and
larger subproblems for larger
and larger substrings.
That gives kind of a
different perspective
on dynamic programming.
And for different
problems, sometimes it's
better to think about either
this sort of top-down recursion
based process, or the
bottom-up process that I'm
describing here.
They're really
completely equivalent.
The version that's described
for this particular algorithm,
which appears in the
textbook, is actually
the bottom-up algorithm.
So you shouldn't be confused
if you see something there
which looks somewhat different.
You basically solve all
possible subproblems,
basically filling out a table.
Let me not say anything
more about that here,
since we're running a
little short on time.
There are really
two perspectives
on dynamic programming.
So moving on from there,
let's shift gears.
Leave context-free languages
and dynamic programming behind.
And so I'm moving toward
understanding P and NP.
And for that, we will
introduce a new problem called
the satisfiability problem.
And that's one we're going
to spend a lot of time on.
If you tuned out a little bit
during the dynamic programming
discussion, time to
get back on board.
The satisfiability
problem is going
to be a computational
problem that we're
going to be working on.
And it has to do
with Boolean formula.
So these are expressions,
like arithmetical formula,
like x plus y times
z, but instead
of using numerical
variables, we're
going to be using Boolean
variables that take
on Boolean values, true, false.
Or sometimes
represented by 1 and 0.
The operators that
we're going to be using
are going to be the and,
or, and negation operations.
And, or, not.
I'm going to say such a
formula, such a Boolean formula,
we're going to call
it satisfiable--
we'll do an example
in a second--
if that formula value
evaluates to true
if you make some assignment
of values to its variables.
So just like arithmetical
formula will have some value
if you plug in values
for the variables,
Boolean formula is
going to have some value
if you plug in Boolean
values for its variables.
And I want to know,
is there some way
to plug in values which makes
the whole thing evaluate
to true.
The formula itself
is going to evaluate
to either true or false, and
I wanted to evaluate to true.
Here is our example.
Let's take the formula,
phi, which is x or y,
and x complement--
or, not x or not y.
So the notation x with a
bar over it, x complement,
is just x bar, not x.
It's just the way
if you're familiar
with the other notation,
the not operation, which
just inverts 1s and 0s.
We're going to write it with
a bar instead of the negation
symbol.
I'm assuming that you've
all seen Boolean algebra,
Boolean arithmetic before,
where the and operation is only
true if both inputs are true.
These are going to be binary
and operations and binary
or operations.
Or is going to be true
if either input is true.
And not is true if its
single input is false.
Oops, just looked at the answer.
Here I want to know, for
this Boolean formula,
here is it satisfiable.
Is there some way to assign
values to the variables
to make this formula
evaluate to true?
So for example, let's
just try things.
Let's make x and y both true.
So x is true and y is true.
So x or y, well that's
good, that's true.
But now we have to do an and, so
we need both sides to be true.
So now we have x complement--
well we said we said x is true,
so x complement is false,
y complement is false.
False or false is false.
So now we have a true and false.
That's going to be false.
We did not find a
satisfying assignment.
But maybe there's another one.
And in fact, there is.
If you make x true and y
false, then both of these parts
will evaluate to true, and
then you'll have true and true.
So we found a satisfying
assignment to this formula.
It is, in fact, satisfiable.
So if you say x is
1 and y is 0, yes.
This is satisfiable.
Now the problem of testing
for a Boolean formula,
if it is satisfiable, is
going to be the SAT language.
It's a set.
It's a collection of
satisfiable Boolean formula.
And testing whether
you're in SAT or not
is going to be an important
computational problem.
There was an amazing
theorem which
really got this
whole subject going,
discovered independently by
Steve Cook in North America
and Leonid Levin in the former
Soviet Union, almost exactly at
the same time, which made a
connection between this one
problem and all of
the problems in NP.
By solving this one
satisfiability problem
in polynomial
time, it allows you
to solve all of the problems
in NP in polynomial time.
So if you could solve
this problem set in P,
then Hamiltonian path
is also solvable in P.
If you step back and think about
that, it's kind of amazing.
And the method that
we're going to introduce
is called polynomial
time reducibility.
Let's do a quick
check-in on this.
This should be an easy one.
Why don't you just think
about, is SAT, the SAT problem
that we just described
here, is that in NP?
Three seconds.
You all there?
OK.
Ending polling.
Hopefully you're getting
the intuition for NP
that these are the
problems-- to be in NP means
that when you're a
member of the language,
there's a short proof or a
short certificate of membership.
And in this case,
the short certificate
that the formula is
satisfiable is the assignment,
which makes it true, also called
the satisfying assignment.
So yes, this is an NP language,
language that's in NP.
There are a lot of things that
we don't know in the subject,
but this isn't one of them.
We do know that SAT is in NP.
So let's talk about
our method for showing
this remarkable
fact that, if you
can solve SAT in polynomial
time, then all of NP
is solvable in polynomial time.
And it uses this notion of
polynomial time reducibility,
which is just like
mapping reducibility
that I hope you've all
grown to know and love
in the first half of the course.
But now, the reduction has to
operate in polynomial time.
So it's the same picture that
we had before, mapping A to B,
transforming A questions
to B questions.
But now the transformation
has to operate quickly.
And we get that if A is
polynomial time reducible to B,
and B is polynomial time, then
A is also polynomial time.
Same pattern as before.
If A is reducible to B and
B is easy, then A is easy.
Here is kind of the
essence of the idea,
or at least the outline of the
idea of this Cook and Levin
theorem.
That if satisfiable is in
P, then everything in NP
can be done in P. Which
is because, we will
show that all problems
in NP are polynomial time
reducible to SAT.
That's the amazing fact.
So therefore, if you
can bring SAT down
into P by using this reduction,
it brings everything else along
with it, everything
is reducible to SAT.
So we just have to
show how to do that.
There is an analogy that
we had in the first half
of the course, in one of
our homework problems,
if you may remember.
We showed that A TM has
the very special property
that all Turing
recognizable languages are
mapping reducible to it.
I think that was problem 2,
or 2a, either in problem set 3
or problem set 2.
I think problem set 3.
That every Turing
recognizable language
is polynomial time
reducible to A TM.
And so, very similar picture.
And there's a lot
of analogies here
that you can draw between
the computability section
and the complexity section.
With that, I know we're
just about out of time.
So let's just quick review
of what we've done here.
I will stick around for
questions for a while.
Is there a--
OK, that's a good question.
Is there a regular
reduction analogy version
to mapping reducibility?
We had the general reduction
for the computability section.
And we had the mapping reduction
Here, we're only going
to be focusing now
on the mapping reduction.
So polynomial time
reduction is, by assumption,
going to be a mapping reduction.
Yes, there is a general
polynomial time reduction
notion as well.
This is not required,
but if you are
curious about the
general reduction
and how to precisely
formulate that,
it actually appears in chapter
6 under Turing reducibility.
That's the general notion
of reducibility spelled out
in a formal way.
And there's polynomial time
Turing reducibility as well.
We're not going to talk
about it in this course.
Other questions?
Does NP correspond
exactly to verification
in polynomial time?
For me to answer that
as a precise question,
we have to have a precise
definition of verification.
But with the right
definition, the answer is yes.
So you can define a verifier
as a polynomial time algorithm
that gives a
certificate, that takes
a certificate and an
input to the language,
and will accept if
that certificate is
a valid certificate
for that input.
This is actually
discussed in chapter,
I think, 9 of the text.
Now I'm forgetting already,
what's where in the book.
But yeah, you can think of
NP in terms of verification
as the definition.
Is proving P equal NP the same
as proving that a polynom--
actually, I can even make the--
if you want, you can
post public comments too.
I should have done
that in other cases.
Is proving P equal NP
the same as proving
that a polynomial
time non-deterministic
Turing machine N has a
polynomial time deterministic?
Yeah.
Suppose we prove that P equals
NP, which is the minority view,
I would say, the
small minority view.
There are some
people who believe
that that is entirely possible,
and might even be the case.
But that's a very small group.
But yeah, if you
prove P equal NP,
that's the same as saying
that every non-deterministic
polynomial time Turing
machine is going
to have a companion
deterministic polynomial
time Turing machine which
does the same language.
That's exactly what it means.
Bye bye, everybody.